[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
census knowledge is a
spiritual
embodied
holistic type of knowledge
um so it's so it's a way of knowing that
interweaves
the the political and the aesthetic if
you like um so
by the political what i mean is analysis
facts science uh topics that are usually
given a lot of gravitas in our society
and then the aesthetic are things like
arts the body the non-human natural
world all kind of like artistic
endeavors so poetry music pottery dance
um and so sentius knowledge is an is an
interweaving
of these realms the political and the
aesthetic
you could also say that it is
interweaving other worlds that don't
typically
uh
uh
meet um partly because of this political
and aesthetic divide so academic uh
analysis with storytelling
science with arts
uh
of course uh reason with emotion
um and so it's really a way of
of
bringing those uh world into into
conversation with each other
and the reason that that is important is
because this is the way that we we live
our lives um you know so we need a kind
of holistic approach to
knowledge and to our ways of knowing
that correspond with
the way that we are human
um and
i give the example of
a yoruba philosophy
called ogbon inu and obonori in my book
sentience knowledge
ogbon inu is literally
translated
knowledge of of the god and oban ori is
knowledge of the head so you could say
correspondingly emotional intelligence
and
sort of rational thinking
and in europe mythology
this concept ogbon which is what
translates to knowledge
is not seen as complete
until or unless
are interwoven
and so sentient knowledge is a kind of
combination of
of these both types of knowledge
i contrast census knowledge to
what i refer to as your patriarchal
knowledge
and
in contrast to this kind of uh
interweaving approach to knowing your
patriarchal knowledge
distinguishes and separates and divides
between the political and the aesthetic
as i defined them earlier
so it's a it's an approach to to knowing
which is um fragmenting
binary it has a lot of hierarchies
and these are uh
dividing and separating between
the body and the mind
so it might be interesting to mention at
this point that um the the
the term sensuous which was coined by
john milton um and he coined it because
he was looking for a word with which to
describe his genre poetry
and he found that sensual was uh you
know it's too connected to the kind of
the bodily pleasures um and sensuous in
contrast
combines the mind the body and the
spirit
um and so
again census knowledge is really honing
in on those uh
interconnections
um
and
your patriarchal knowledge on the other
hand makes these divisions um
not only to sort of
it's not for the sake of of being
divisive it is so that it can kind of
control knowledge production and the
more that it can control knowledge
production the more that it can also
create a system in which
categories of of humans and of
non-humans can also be controlled
[Music]
there's kind of two aims in sensors
knowledge so one is to
to to develop
this
form of knowledge and a form of an
approach to knowledge which is sensuous
and which is holistic and embodied
and the other is to
connect that with the kind of black
feminist
thinking that has been produced over the
decades
so black feminism is
the only ideology really that has looked
at the ways in which different forms of
systemic oppression are connected
um so it has
analyzed how uh women are oppressed how
people of different class backgrounds
and of different racial backgrounds are
also victims of of suppression and that
is because black women historically have
tended to embody
both class oppression as well as racial
and gender oppression
um
black feminist ideology and it's
important to to emphasize that when i'm
speaking about black feminism i'm not
talking about black feminist individuals
but quite uh sort of
the the typical
arguments in black feminist thought
and so black feminist thought aside from
looking at race class and gender has
also had a connection to spirit if you
like and to the arts um so as i
described earlier census knowledge is
also
being a black feminist theory it kind of
combines those worlds
black women have historically around the
world been excluded from institutions of
power um including educational
institutions and leadership institutions
and so we have had to
look
to other sources to other realms through
which we can uh not only
produce knowledge but produce knowledge
that works toward liberation black
feminist thought has consequently
cultivated a type of knowledge
production using
communication with the natural world if
you like and and that in itself has a it
has a poetic and a spiritual quality to
it as
communication and communing with nature
typically does
[Music]
so joy is uh equality or maybe i should
even say political joy um is something
that is uh it's important not only for
black women i should add but maybe
especially for black women and in this
context i'm certainly looking at
us as a group
but for everyone
and the reason that that political joy
matters is because joy is a quality that
cannot really be
suppressed so when
when we feel joy both individually and
collectively we are far less likely to
be suppressed by
powerful and ceramic forces in society
so it's a little bit like if you were to
think of an of an intimate relationship
um in which there is an abuser and the
abused
it is much more difficult to abuse
somebody who feels a kind of internal
political conscientious joy you could
say
it is similar when we when we think
about this as a collective
um
of course
political joy doesn't solve every
problem
but it is it is certainly a quality that
is really important to cultivate but
also because that is
uh
the characteristic the sentiment that we
have been denied for so long in in
oppressive systems
i think that this this kind of political
joy is something that arises
almost from a combination of of
rage and
desire
so there's when we feel
anger toward the injustices that that we
face in society um but we also feel
desire for something different um
and i think that uh most people are
driven by
three desires of sorts so there's the
desire to
have meaningful connections with with
others and i would include uh non-human
others as well in that um there's desire
to
to see a better society to see
transformation in society we we all kind
of feel crippled and impeded by uh
political suffering
um and then we feel a desire to
to acquire knowledge um to to acquire
clarity about ourselves and about the
societies in which we live
and those desires together when you
merge them um
they kind of bring us forth toward joy
um but they also reveal the places in
which uh there are obstacles for
achieving those desires and so they they
also sort of generate a sense of anger
and political joys is almost what comes
when you still resolve uh to try to
pursue those things
um the type of and this is why uh
sensuous knowledge is relevant because
the type of
knowledge that
or the kind of approach to knowledge in
order that you can achieve these three
desires
is one that needs to be
malleable and um and and uh holistic and
and kind of
it's it's knowledge it's treating
knowledge almost as you would treat a
lover so having having an intimate
relationship with knowledge um rather
than one that is rigid and unmalleable
um and so you can you can um you know
when you have this type of approach to
knowledge you you
you can do away with things with
knowledge that no longer serves its
purpose if you realize that something is
no longer producing the outcome
that that particular type of epistemic
tradition was was intending to do then
you can do away with it
simultaneously you can
you look for knowledge and sources that
you're not encouraged to look for
knowledge in so this is uh going back to
finding knowledge in in rivers or in in
sculptures or in movement and so on
[Music]
so the first thing i'll say about that
is that when i'm speaking about your
patriarchal knowledge i'm i'm speaking
about a kind of epistemic approach um so
it's it's really uh it's centering on
narrative and kind of the social
imaginary that that we share
rather than looking at the structure
that is euro patriarchy which also
exists um but there it's kind of
necessary to separate the two because
when we think about uh the epistemic
production of your patriarchal knowledge
um what emerges is that it is not all
negative in the way that your
patriarchal structures are all negative
because they are meant to sort of
oppress and divide and create hierarchy
but your patriarchal knowledge is
responsible for instance for
modern universities a lot of modern
organizations
um encyclopedias and things like that so
it has uh produced objects and ways of
thinking that are of value to the human
species at large
um
and so
when it comes to how we move forward um
and you know
integrating sensuous knowledge into
a way of moving forward um it would mean
to
uh
like i spoke about earlier it's like
taking what is useful from different
elements in society um and absolutely
then reconfiguring and creating
something that is completely different
to to to the epistemic approaches that
we have today
um
but i would not say that it is just
about
creating uh
black schools or female schools or
anything like that so the content of
education and the approach toward
education is far more important than
actually the kind of
connection to identity to race to gender
to class um that said of course uh
there's there's huge value in um and it
and it is an absolute necessity if we
are going to have a completely different
way of knowing and rebuild society in
ways that we can all exist in a in a
higher dimension of sorts
it is essential to talk about
race gender and class
and all other kinds of
divisions in society
um and also uh things that are emerging
as major divisive factors in society
today such as surveillance capitalism
and of course uh the climate emergency
we need to to educate children from a
very young age about these things and
how they are connected to a type of
knowledge that has reigned supreme for
so long
but that also needs to be what really
needs to be cultivated is a is a
different approach to it all
and that needs to be one which which
brings in
the the whole human
um and the whole human's relationship
not only to itself but to others as well
as to the non-human natural world so
that's really what lies at the center of
essentia's knowledge
[Music]
i think the writing is
an essential part of reconstructuring
and of
reimagining and unlearning
ways that have been harmful for so long
um
and maybe it's maybe
even more than writing it is uh
language words meaning
um that that conveys and and that helps
us as a human species to tell stories
about who we are
you see the issue is that we have it's
almost as though the language we have
and the writing that we have
had that has shaped the kind of
universal concepts that impact all of
our lives for so long
hasn't been
the complete story uh therefore
rendering it actually incorrect um
untrue
if you like
so when you have a small group of people
uh you know however progressive and and
smart they may be so you know all of the
kind of key shapers of universal
concepts like power and identity and and
the arts and
beauty and things like that which are
the topics that i address in my book um
for for
centuries they've been defined by one
small group of people sometimes expertly
very often with huge flaws and violence
but even worse than the kind of
repercussions uh
that that type of knowledge production
has created in society is that
it has actually not aided us
collectively as a human species in
achieving epistemic truth
um it's like looking at a mountain from
just one side of the mountain all you
can see is what it looks like from there
and if you then went out and and you
know wrote wrote a book about that you
would be given
you would just be given a kind of half
truth to people
what happens when we bring in
voices and thoughts and practices
from groups of people that have seen you
know many different sides of the
mountain is that it changes the language
it changes the meaning of what a
mountain itself is
um and that is the kind of project that
the writing um of a certain kind anyway
is is is engaged with uh it's certainly
what i what i um
see my writing is doing um so i would
say that my writing typically
arrives at two different kinds of of
places
one in which
i am seeking to demystify
um and dismantle
knowledge that is untrue knowledge that
is limiting
um
and on the other hand i am seeking to
to unearth the truth almost in the way
that an archaeologist would would uh
sort of excavate everything that's in
the way of them finding that that thing
that they're looking for
and in that process of unearthing and
excavating um
the the the parts of the story that are
untold um are in some way they become
ethereal because they've been hidden for
so long they've been obscured and so
while it's all very real there's
something about uh the writing that is
also
magical in some sense because it is
revealing parts of human history that
have been hidden
not not necessarily
like alternative
parts of human history but rather hidden
parts
[Music]
so a huge motivation for me
writing census knowledge is actually my
lived experience
i
grew up in lagos in nigeria
very cosmopolitan city also a really
patriarchal one and one which is
influenced or
admired in neocolonial
patterns
as a teenager i moved to to sweden
and
there i encountered a very racialized
reality um
i was you know i hadn't really
been a racialized person before that um
but i encountered
not only that i was seen as black but
also that that meant that i would be uh
the recipient of both verbal and
physical abuse
um and then i
i moved to spain for a while i lived in
new york for some years before moving to
london and um in all of these these
places um i guess i i always felt like i
didn't i didn't fully fit so
um
i i didn't quite have a home
it was first in in
black feminist thought that i in many
ways found a home um
an intellectual and a spiritual home of
sorts
of course i bring my own nuance also to
black feminist thought and so i had um
you know i have this background which is
uh african scandinavia and i've lived in
in the us in different parts of europe
um
and i've always felt that i didn't quite
fit in and what that has meant for me is
that i see the world from a kind of
multi-perspectival lens
and i have felt frustrated living in
societies where uh only one part of
myself was ever allowed to exist when i
knew
that it is possible uh you know to to
exist as a multi-perspectival human
being um and and and that that actually
could be really enriching especially
when it came to knowledge production
because whatever issue i was looking at
i was able to look at it from these
different prisons i i speak several
languages as well so i could really you
know
unpack an issue um but everywhere i i
went um
what i encountered was that you know we
were we were being told that there is
only this one way of looking at
something and that is the right way
[Music]
yeah
i would encourage that people
read broadly of course you know read
read literature fiction and non-fiction
and poetry and myths and all of that
from um
from one's local vicinity and and far
and wide across the world
but but even more than reading um you
know as i as i spoke about in the very
beginning census knowledge is uh is a
way of interweaving different worlds
together so it's it's um you know it's
by no means saying that uh emotional
intelligence is is is better than say
rational thinking or that that
storytelling is better than science or
anything like that and so um a an
approach essentials approach to
knowledge would involve
whatever topic that you burn for and
that you're looking to to understand
better or to transform um to look at it
from all of the possible angles that you
can so from
the political and from the aesthetic but
also uh you know one of the things that
i i do in my book is i um i have a
conversation with rivers about power
um and that of course sounds very
whimsical but um uh what i do kind of
try to develop a language through which
i can talk to rivers and other elements
of nature and i call that language
exulsions um and you know that's another
way of
of trying to
understand um something like power which
for so long has been defined in very
rigid ways as synonymous to coercion to
violence to dominance um and and you
know there's a need to redefine
something like power because if we are
interested in changing power structures
because
patriarchal thought cannot undo
patriarchal structures this is an
example
of how i apply accentuous knowledge to a
topic like like power um but you could
you could think of it um
you could break it down to something as
simple as what you had for breakfast in
the morning uh you know as a kind of
fun thought experiment if you had a
slice of toast with butter
and say you wanted to understand what
what is this thing that i ate um you
know you could think about it
scientifically so the the calorific uh
and nutritional
intake um you could also think about it
in terms of your senses you know how
what was the texture of the bread what
did it smell like what did it taste like
um you could think about
artists that have painted loafs of bread
or something like that um and that
really is the way that we you know if
you kind of practice looking at even the
simplest most mundane things in that way
then it
starts to become easier to also look at
a political movement like feminism in
that way as well as the the oppositional
forces to something like feminism
[Music]
yeah so in the book i argue that um
the beauty cannot exist in an oppressive
system basically
so anything that is beautiful in a
system of oppression is beautiful
despite rather than because of it
the rapper took shakur he he in one of
his songs he says it's uh
he speaks about a rose growing out of
concrete um so beauty in europe
patriarchy is a little bit like two
fracture cores rose growing out of
concrete
and it's important to preface that when
we're speaking about beauty because
the way that we
typically
think about beauty
which is you know beauty is such an
important
topic for for women particularly um and
that by the way is because uh you know
part of this this language around beauty
has
for so long been to say that women can
be beautiful while men are handsome and
when we think that way then of course uh
we end up politicizing beauty but not
handsomeness and that produces a kind of
circular logic that we can objectify
women but not men um
but
what we uh what what is what your
patriarchal knowledge does with the
topic like beauty is to
is what it does to everything every
other topic which is to try and measure
and quantify and create hierarchies
around beauty um so throughout history
you have theories like the golden ratio
which you know tries to to pinpoint
exactly what makes a person beautiful um
you have william hogart had a theory
about what he called the line of beauty
um
and
this all ends up reproducing uh systems
in which
beauty is used as one of the foremost
tools of oppression against women
and
women have to
kind of understand how this mechanism
works in order to transform it
and so i
distinguish between three different
types of beauty which i call political
beauty artificial beauty and genuine
beauty
the point of that is to really
ultimately
uh
look at beauty from a woman-centered
perspective and to re-imagine it
political beauty is very much
it's as it implies you know it's beauty
that is tied to a political agenda and
that political agenda is one which is
heteronormative
ableist
and
elitist and and of course patriarchal
artificial beauty is is connected with
political beauty in that it tries to it
is kind of uh
you know creating the illusion the
facades of beauty so it's it's where
capitalism comes in
um and and it solidifies and enforces
the political agenda behind political
beauty whereas genuine beauty is uh you
know i build that around uh toni
morrison's beautiful phrase where she
says we shouldn't only observe beauty
but do beauty um so genuine beauty is a
kind of doing beauty
um and
from that
perspective you know
you can see that beauty while beauty may
not be
democratic you know every everybody has
different um
tastes what i find beautiful you might
not find beautiful and so on um but it
certainly allows for for an openness
which includes
people of all backgrounds of all race
sex class
backgrounds as well as people who are
disabled people who are
um you know
have different religious backgrounds
it's it's really creating an
open-mindedness and almost i would say
a
non-conformity and an anarchism around
beauty because what your patriarchal
knowledge um does you know and it's so
absurd is that it it's really looking to
to to measure and box in
something as as anarchic and
non-conformist as beauty so so what
genuine beauty does is reclaim that
sense of
freedom and play um and and uh kind of
agency to to to define beauty as one
wants and um and to be
uh
kind of you know i always say be your
own beauty icon um
and that applies to all groups and all
individuals
[Music]
so there isn't a formula um for how to
do beauty precisely because it is
because i see beauty as something
non-conforming um but i will give you a
a metaphor of a garden
um so
if beauty were a garden then political
beauty would be a garden in which
everything was really neatly placed and
sort of uh identical looking and there
would be the highest point and the
lowest point and so on you get the
picture of artificial beauty where a
garden then it would be a garden into
which you stepped and
uh and everything you touched would turn
out to be an illusion so you'd you'd
pluck a beautiful strawberry and it
would just not exist in your hand
you'd look into a pond and you wouldn't
see your reflection
so everything would be artificial
if genuine beauty were a garden it would
be one in which
there's a where everything is kind of uh
there's hybridity um things are
uh growing on top of each other or not
growing at all
um but what would the quality that would
emerge would be uh
a sense of something everlasting
um so you would be in that garden and
you would feel that this is this is
something that has existed from the very
beginnings and will always exist and and
and you would be able to just kind of
be there to find a space where you
you exist your presence is there but the
garden's presence is also there and
there's a kind of
an
ecology of beauty if you like
um
and so by sharing this metaphor uh you
know i think
if we
if we carry that in our spirit um when
we are looking at how um
you know who
every year there's an announcement of
the most beautiful woman in the world or
you know if we look at uh
instagram influencers or or objective
objectified women in advertisements etc
um
or far more insidiously uh you know the
ways in which uh people are punished for
not fitting to very strict beauty
standards and of course also the kind of
racism that is embedded into beauty
standards
if we bear this metaphor of the garden
in our minds
then
hopefully the way that we understand
what is happening around us
will one not impact us um to the point
that we we start to self-harm um
at the point at which we start to to
self-harm and i don't necessarily mean
that uh as a as a sort of physical thing
that we do um but politically self-harm
then europe patriarchal knowledge
has kind of won
um and this you know goes back to
uh political joy so
with this metaphor of the garden when
there's a uh
an interest in making us
uh to feel deprived of beauty
um
then we kind of
that that's where uh sensuous knowledge
and the cultivation of political joy and
this metaphor of the garden uh can can
help to like re-center and regroup uh
when we speak of a collective
um
and and hopefully
uh open up
a a path to doing beauty and not just
observing beauty
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
you